avec vous trouvez jeanne moreau lance
même un pareil à lui même il est
toujours sympathique
je joue très bien
elle est formidable quelle est la scène
que vous avez préféré tout en général je
peux pas est ce que ça vous a choqué la
scène d'amour entre le moine trappiste
et l'iguane chiant je m'étais beaucoup
de monde et lorsque le shérif et l'amour
au chef abyei est un symbole pour vous
oui oui bien sûr lequel il ya
l'amour de une attirance mutuelle vous
avez pleuré à la fin du film lorsque
bambi dénoncent sa mère aux allemands il
ya toujours une petite émotion quelle
est la meilleure scène de film à votre
avis la meilleure bas vers le début
quand j'ai pas vu le fils d'un couple
dont n'importe quoi qu'elle est on
reprend quelle est la meilleure scène du
film à votre avis la meilleure scène du
film toy lembras quel est à votre avis
la plus belle scène du film
au début quand on voit qu'ils marchent
quand le troupeau d'éléphants rentrer
dans sacré coeur sur la musique du
dernier et 47 our lives de georgette
lemaire ça vous a plu cette scène
ouais mais je trouve ce sont des
situations extrêmement improbable et
quelle est la casquette que vous avez
préféré la cascade la cascade
quand il se jette du vide mais il se
jette dans le vide ça a été un crève les
séquences la séquence c'est quand ça
dans le vers la fin quand ici avec la
voiture
c'est un film en costumes d'époque ya
pas de voiture non mais attendez qu est
ce que vous racontez c'est pour inventer
des conneries c'est quoi la peur mais je
n'ai pas vu outils
alors pourquoi vous m'en parlez ce n'est
pas lui c'est à 100 c'est notre
comportement
qu'est ce que je vous ai dit mais c'est
insensé ça vraiment les gens veulent
parler de tout sans jamais rien la
voirie et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu